scp-682 vs scp-826  these magical dragon bookends can really  bring fiction to life but could they  make the dream of killing scp-682 a  reality a short story written by a  researcher entitled the generally nice  friendly thing that canon will kill  scp-682 permanently if it so much as  spots that damn lizard which we can  imagine was very cathartic to write was  placed between the bookends a d-class on  a motorcycle lured scp-682 into this new  fantasy world to fight the generally  nice friendly thing and an epic battle  between the two unfolded however when  the battle came to an end 682 lived and  the thing had been torn apart when it  was returned to its containment chamber  the title of the book had become the  generally nice friendly thing that tried  to kill scp-682 permanently but failed  with almost 200 extra pages detailing  the epic but ultimately fruitless battle